congratulations you just had a daughter
that cracked it is this your first child
my first chat my wife did all the work
I don't man because Andy and I have been
through this not together but you each
have two kids but you are now going
through this amazing life experience
how's it going what's your interest in
going it's been going it's not as hard
as people say uh you know people always
[ __ ] moaning and complaining but like I
had enough training before I got into
this like I've boozed hard until like
4:00 in the morning and had to get up at
8:00 like my whole life great load
trucks go do a gig or something like
that so I'm kind of used to it so you're
used to this no sleep thing you've done
this before
yeah all right catch flights in Justino
stumbling through the airport going to
the your seat assignment rather than the
gate and then having to switch it up so
if you I've been through it yeah so uh I
can't believe you think those are the
same but all right know what I'm going
Shuman life it's about a human life here
trying to tone it down cuz everybody
gets you all freaked out like parents
are the worst they're crazy people I
mean other people with kids yeah yeah
parents yeah people with kids yeah I'm
with you now okay Abbas I was boos until
4:00 in the morning then I went to the
airport I don't know I'm a little out of
it so so what are they bored they
driving you crazy what are you talking
about because all they did was just
bring anxiety like I thought it would be
this great thing to have a kid that
should tell other people no I'm gonna
kid oh yeah you know no more doing this
no more doing that you know just make it
a seemed like it was going to be this
miserable experience and it's been I
mean I'm only ten days in but it's it's
good and taking the car out or anything
yeah that's spent all right have you had
like so friends or they're giving you
advice they're sending you advice what
are they doing you they're texting you
advice what's happening this kid sent me
guys sent me this video ago a my
daughter took the first steps ever and
I'm and he goes to Semyon in the it's
his daughter she's not wearing a shirt
which feels like all right they do that
in the diaper commercials that's fine
and then what you press play is like
over a goods and I press play and the
kids completely naked just sitting there
like walking like that
yeah I hit stop delete and I was gonna
text him like do don't send me like
naked photos are you kid a video you
ever watched look to catch a predator I
don't understand people they like upload
pictures of the kids on the internet
they put like the little stick figures
on the back of the car like mom dad how
many kids the dog like the whole menu
yeah but the serial killer sitting
behind you at the red light like why
would you do that
I don't give out as little information
as possible don't send me naked videos
are you kid you weirdo yeah not cute you
just sounds on my phone for like three
days I didn't check it out then I
finally looked at it and for like the
next four hours I'm in my house every
time a helicopter went over I told this
guy he thinks it's cute I don't
I only want point eight seconds of it I
got Jesus alright we'll settle down it's
gonna be fine
you know you're just a naked kid video
okay alright the important thing is that
when you what you know I I watch other
people with their kids and I thought if
they could do what I could do it you
know that's what that's what calmed me
down a little yes I saw this complete
animal in the grocery store just walking
with this kid like he had him like
thrown over his shoulder like a beach
towel and he was trying to find where
his wife was and he just looked like
such a [ __ ] I remember just thinking if
this guy can keep that alive I can't
explain the vacant look on this guy you
know walk I was bursted out laughing
when I looked at him it's like you're a
dad alright
you